ja ich hab dich schon nacht gesehen das
heißt aber nicht dass ich ja sicher auch
schon mal gesehen hat kann man nicht mal
wanne und ich bin heute nicht alleine
hier und zwar habe ich der die frau am
start up a power password acar totally
spies karin miriam an veronika
schaufensterpuppen im random so finster
wie alec tut uns in schaufenster
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe mir eine kleine halloween
challenge ausgedacht und zwar müsst ihr
euch die situation vorstellen
ihr seid gerade auf einer party
eingeladen wurden an spontan und mit dem
anruf aus d lux verbraucher plant im
seitenteil volk vergessen sich
einzuladen
also allem abgesagt wird sie nicht und
eigentlich hat schon jeder laden zu was
macht ihr zu dm gehen und ihr seid brook
10 euro nehmen wo wir stehen dm hierfür
geld den euro den euro für jeden von uns
jederzeit halbe stunde können müssen
laufen über shopping queen
[Musik]
wir sind wieder zurück sei jetzt ein
haar machen ja ich habe genau 925
ausgegeben ich habe auch 925 ausgegeben
arbeit hat den kraftstoff e10
wir verraten uns noch gegenseitig nicht
als was wir uns verkleiden wir werden
uns gleich reparieren und dann uns
vorstellen kulig küchentücher gekauft
farbe spree und als faktischer und
binden
ich habe auch küchentücher auch binden
aber andere eine netzstrumpfhose hier
solange haargummis und ein roten
lippenstift also ich hab ne rücken
schon 22 schäumt spareinlagen in leopard
masken und wu im angebot für 1 euro es
müssen beschiss aber man findet immer
flaschen wein also lasst uns beginnen
transformation
[Musik]
ach so du musst einfach einstecken und
dann geht's los
wenn's irgendwo her dann abläuft so was
mache ich eigentlich gerade habe ich
nicht irgendwem oder haarspülung leute
daran sein dass ich heute mit roten
fahnen club gehe ich auch das okay ich
luke an tipps ja also am besten was
drunter liegen definitiv nicht das
gleiche ach das ist ja interessant
ich hab's der passte mir fällt es aber
erstmal auch wenn ich bastele ein
zeitlimit bis waren wir das fertig haben
naja die party beginnt gleich noch so
hoch dass oft des jahres so wir müssen
jetzt aufstehen eine überleitung zu
kriminalisieren
ich mache das schon mal richtig aber
meinen verstimmt wärmer
das von uns täglich gefühl haben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also ich rate mal ja du bist ein tampon
ist ein terrorist aber das detail sieht
man ja gar nicht wo es festgemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
denkmal
zum kauf
[Musik]
und raum geben
und ja
[Musik]
ja das sind unsere zehn euro kostüme dir
selbstverständlich gerne nachmachen
wollte prince tagoe autobahn ja und da
wünsche ich dir einen in suchen kleinen
herrentag immerhin 48 wer das beste kost
und schaut bei uns vorbei wir haben auch
halloween videos kann ja und wenn ihr
nichts weiter verpassen wollten
abonniert milch und abonnieren
alles was ihr bei mein kostüm ist echt
eklig